[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream our 33rd
q and a i am here with dr heather heing
i understand there has been some
consternation in the chat about the
absence of my
bandana face mask let me explain
i went for a ride this morning to see
what was happening in the undeclared
autonomous zone
in downtown portland this morning and
when i came back
my mask was predictably soaked with
sweat so i took it off and i forgot to
put one back on
so that's what happened
awesome yeah all right
it's it's a it's an answer to an implied
question
yes it is it is okay so we're going to
start uh as has become our habit with a
couple of questions from
episode 32 that we didn't get to that i
thought warranted us returning to
and then we'll launch into the
uh top questions from last hour the top
questions in terms of
of monetary value one
is there no merit to partially defunding
the police and reallocating those funds
to other organizations that would handle
some of the misplaced responsibilities
that police currently handle
none let me explain no there's none
um if this were an honest argument then
the point is well but
okay i mean go for it but i would like i
think that this is asked as if
you know what would the honest argument
sound like and the honest argument does
have merit oh the honest argument has
merit and you know
it's not like we haven't decried the
militarization of police
and uh i know that for a couple of
decades i've been
talking about the hazard of private
prisons
and the perverse incentive that it
creates all these things but
but specifically you know the
reallocation of funds
for other organizations to do things
that police have come to do
right and i mean this is something that
you've talked about um before
actually you know why why are police the
first line of defense when people are
having mental health crises on the
streets
right is that is that really the right
job for police
right so um so absolutely there is
room to imagine reconfiguring
how resources are spent and who would be
the best people to deal with various
jobs
the problem is i don't want to help
these people construct their mod
this is a modern bailey and here's the
problem
there is no logical reason to connect
these two things
okay there may be too much in police
budgets
i don't know if there is or there isn't
i am certain that
it is not optimally allocated i do not
know if anybody can spell out what the
optimal allocation would be
however should there be more dedicated
to
social programs that make the police
less necessary of course
should there be less in the police
budgets certainly following
the rendering of police as unnecessary i
look forward to seeing uh a reduction in
police forces by virtue of the fact that
we're spending too much on them
but to link these two things as if
taking the funds from the police
is necessary in order to make those
programs work is a garbage argument
demonstrate that we're spending too much
demonstrate that we are spending it in
the wrong way
and then there's a proper response
demonstrate that there's a need for
social programs
then there's an obvious response but to
link these two things
is the mott of amot and bailey and i'm
not interested in playing that game
good again question from last time with
regard to the navy vet whom we spoke
about
on either that one or the previous
episode with regard to this guy having
gone to the protests and having been
beaten
um on camera by uh homeland security
officers
the person says so civil disobedience is
not okay
sit-ins wouldn't have been very
effective if activists listen to police
and vacated lunch counters
yep so civil disobedience is obviously
okay and not okay right are you allowed
to engage in civil disobedience
you know if you get a parking ticket and
you think it was illegitimate are you
allowed to block a freeway
presumably not so the point is this is
actually a
judgment a judgment call and um
i don't actually know what the
explanation is for that vet and
what he did and it's possible that the
idea was to precipitate a reaction that
would be
uh telegenic um in which case
um probably not legit uh on the other
hand
there are certainly instances in which
such a thing can be done for the right
reason and maybe has to be done for the
right reason
so it's a judgment call it is not
inherently okay
that it is civil disobedience civil
disobedience is a category that can be
okay and can be necessary
but in this case it looked like um
it's feeding a false narrative which is
that um
the feds don't need to be here that they
are engaged in
a fascist crackdown because trump
and you know that's sort of the extent
of the argument and for people living in
portland
facing uh the prospect of having
police failing to enforce the laws that
keep us safe
uh it's not so simple it just isn't yeah
and my history may fail me here but um
sit-ins and uh and lunch counters
lunch counter sit-ins and such from the
60s uh
were in part a response to selectively
racially biased policing for sure
and so there was civil disobedience
against
police but i do not believe and this is
where i'm just i'm
i'm not sure and i'm sure we'll hear
about it if i'm wrong that there was a
con commitment move and if so it
certainly wasn't a majority move
uh to abolish all of the police so with
the abolish the police move that is
happening right now
if you add that to civil disobedience
you have now justified
any single thing that involves resisting
anything police might do
which obviously immediately leads to
anarchy yeah it immediately is anarchy
and you know
obviously lunch counters black people
had a right to eat at those lunch
counters to the extent that they were
barred sitting down at those lunch
counters was
a very natural response likewise rosa
parks refusing to
uh give up her seat why should she give
up her seat so
the point is those were actually
absolutely natural outgrowths of the
oppression in question whereas um
uh flaunting the law of
flouting the law of the state of oregon
the city of portland
is a different matter and tied up in
nonsense um to play
devil's advocate for a moment uh it is
very easy um
retrospectively uh to say obviously
rosa parks was was right and having
segregated drinking fountains and lunch
counters was wrong
and we can see that with such clarity
and we would all have been on the right
side of history and of course most
people would not have been on the right
side of history because we know that
from well
history so um it's not
that there will be a hundred percent
clarity
uh with regard to when civil
disobedience is appropriate and when
it's not
um but when it is being blankly applied
to every single
thing that any kind of policing force
might do
you know there's something else afoot
next question totally different with
regard to longevity in science fiction
in hinds methuselah's children ageless
humans are created through artificial
selection
in p anderson's the boat of a million
years ageless humans are created through
natural selection is either possible
um no unless you're willing to extend
the definition
in other words of which uh agelessness
human okay
no i mean look if you're willing to buy
something like the
upload of a human consciousness to an
artificial structure
then there's no bar to indefinite
longevity it's not possible yet but it
might be
it's not biotically possible but the
fact is there is no reason to think
well some people would disagree with
this i think they're
all missing the point but there's no
reason to think there's anything
calculated in a mind
that could not be produced in a
computing environment
now we are not remotely close to this
and frankly we haven't even really
understood how the mind works well
enough to even spell out what the job is
but we've still got some crazy blueprint
version of an understanding
yeah and unless unless you are one of
one of these pan psychist people who
believe that the particles themselves
have something to do with consciousness
then the point is they're calculations
of some kind and
um to the extent that they are
calculations of some kind they can be
in an environment where you have
indefinitely large amounts of energy and
potentially
uh indefinitely large amounts of or
numbers of transistors that can be
brought into play
you can simulate anything right up
through the analog so
yeah you could upload maybe but short of
uploading
can you take this critter and make it
indefinitely long-lived
only if you recognize the absurdity of
the question
how would you do it you would recognize
that lineage is the real thing
right lineages are indefinitely
long-lived
the uh individual
is finite cannot be extended should not
be extended i mean
extend it a bit sure but indefinitely
long-lived individuals would be a
catastrophe
and finally if you did it for the body
and you don't do it for the mind
it's a nightmare scenario so can we stop
dreaming about this garbage and
enjoy the fact that life is delightful
and part of what makes it delightful is
that it's not infinite
good first question
from last hour do the protests and riots
have a stated end goal
i guess it's just abolished the usa you
say quote the police should enforce the
law and i agree but how exactly
what tactics would you use arrest
everyone every night tear gas disperse
money to go home it's a great question
and
in fact it's one that i want to ask some
of the people who are protesting i want
to ask that
uh to the people who are most most
capable of answering it
good um chaos but let's say this
the nature of a riot is that there is a
failure of the ability to enforce the
law
based on the immediacy the suddenness
the fact
of the force being overwhelmed right
it's the same thing that creates looting
is that
you have a force built for normal
circumstances when something abnormal of
sufficient
magnitude arises the force is not
adequate to do it
two months into a reliable riot that's
not where you are
whatever resources need to be brought to
bear on two blocks of portland
is it possible to bring a force large
enough
to deal with law breakers in two blocks
of portland of course it is
so the fact that we're not doing it is
not because it's impossible to figure
out what those tactics might be
it's that there's no will to do it and
the no will to do it at the local level
forces the feds to defend their
buildings
which is then being portrayed as a
fascist incursion etc and so
you know look it's theater it's theater
with uh
you know weapons with weapons and so
weaponized theater let's just not
pretend that it's something else
this is a failure of the local which is
leaving the federal as
the last line of defense and it
shouldn't surprise anybody that there's
some level of
federal enforcement to protect these
buildings that's where we are
yeah and just to speak briefly to the
first question
in this question do the protests or
riots have a stated end goal i haven't
heard it you know we've seen things like
abolish usa
and um you know and defund the police
which in some people's minds means and
the police
um but i will relay an anecdote that
nancy roman
who lived here in portland for 15 years
and just moved away
last year but is back at the moment
reporting for reason
in one of her one of her missives that
is now published
at reason about what is going on here in
the ground in portland she reports just
the conversation with a young just a
slight
girl really like a young woman uh who
probably weighs less than 100 pounds
who's sort of on the front lines um at
the
at the federal building as they as the
protesters are trying to get in this is
well after midnight and
nancy hears her ask somewhat plaintively
what happens if we get in
and and no one answers right and um this
i think
is is telling that um if there is a
stated
end goal it's not shared by even all the
people who are participating
um and by which i don't mean they don't
all agree but
most of them don't even know it so uh
i would say the movement has an end goal
and it is the
capture and wielding of power over
resources
that is where it will cash out for sure
right
the local phenomenon does not
the goal is happening the goal is the
ability to portray what is taking place
as a fascist incursion into portland
um that the new york times will
dutifully report as such
and this is that state we've gotten
there yeah
next question if it is permissible to
litigate past crimes and extract repair
from other groups descendants
might the fact that europeans genome is
two percent neanderthal
given a reparations claim against
african homo sapiens and their
neanderthal
hominid aside yes yes
well i mean this is obviously somewhat
tongue-in-cheek i hope
i assume uh but it does it it does
point to one of the deep and abiding
problems
with asking for a correction of
historical wrongs which is that
uh every single population on the planet
has done wrong and been wronged
that's just that's just part of part of
what is true you know
i had a friend in olympia you know very
liberal very progressive woman
who used to say i don't understand why
we are expected to call
the indigenous native americans first
peoples they weren't the first they
replaced earlier peoples who probably
also weren't the first
they are of the lineage that was first
but
pretending that they were again noble
savages
who you know just lived on the land in
this blissful utopia
no that's that's not what happened so um
yeah there was there there have been
hominid against hominid
uh interactions since they've been
hominids of course there have
yeah now i must say this this feels
personal to me because i strongly
suspect that i have more neanderthal
than
average um but uh yeah but because of
the brow ridge is that right
you know it is what it is but um i'm
just wondering why i've never heard this
before i don't know i just
it resonates for me um so
in any case yeah um no obviously i mean
your point is well made using the
neanderthals and the fact is look
let's just do this the right way you
know um the arc of the moral universe is
long and it bends towards justice that's
obviously the right goal
it remains the right goal we've named it
we have not gotten all the way
to the arc of the end of the arc of the
moral universe but the idea that we are
now
losing the plot of that and going into a
new form of injustice
is just insane yep really really a
tragedy
have you seen ryan long's video when
wokes and racists actually agree on
everything
to me this is the incisive comedic take
we've needed yeah it's
it's fabulous maybe we should actually
link that in the description
we haven't shown it because we don't
really show whole videos but it's
what two or three minutes it's well
worth your time it's beautiful it's very
well done
yeah um next question
what responses are probable or likely if
trump wins in november
how do the streets of america look in
the following weeks that's from elon
tusk
um yeah the uh
i shudder to think um you know
that said again i uh the
danger of biden being elected with
the partnership that he has clearly
formed
with um what even is the right term is
it the movement for black lives is that
what's going on but
in any case the either case is so
unacceptable
that um really uh unity 2020 that's the
point
either case is absolutely unex
unacceptable and the confluence
of the um the aggrieved
side and the way it will understand what
has taken place
um means that the parties have just set
us up for a national catastrophe
we we have to escape their hegemony for
this reason they have set us up
yeah it's uh
it will send us closer to an actual race
war um
and if either one wins honestly there
may be claims that there was
election tampering uh and if there is
any evidence at all of election
tampering that sends us
you know one step a big step closer to
the end of democracy
you know and trump has been setting us
up for
that interpretation he's been tweeting
about the illegitimacy of
uh mail-in ballots and all and so
it won't take much the interpretation
will be that this is a stolen election
almost no matter what happens
um unless of course you vote unity 2020
right what are the chances unity 2020
stole the election i mean that's
impossible
stole it from the rightful heirs
two-party system come on wonderful
yeah uh do you have advice for aspiring
fiction writers outside of the
institution
literature will be crucial for exploring
the intra-psychic and social
complexities of this era
secondly will you read my letter against
ibram candy's anti-racism in schools
that's interesting um i'm actually i
have set myself
the homework of reading uh abram candy
so i'm not gonna read anyone else's
interpretation of it until i do but um i
would be interested in
seeing uh seeing such a letter you know
advice for aspiring fiction writers
we've spoken
uh earlier to the capture
of literature and other art forms by
this movement and it's really it's
really a shame publishing
has been captured books uh get cancelled
by their publishers before they even
go to press in some cases because the
wokes golds say that they're not
you know they were written by the wrong
person with the wrong demographics or
the wrong conclusion or something
so uh one one good thing at the moment
is that it's possible to self-publish
but
uh i i do think just like you know it
feels like an
ages ago but three years ago we were
saying well university of chicago with
the chicago principles
uh should be rising and uh
in you know in terms of all of these
students and parents of students
parents of would-be college students who
are looking for a school that is
actually resistant
to this scourge that is
anti-intellectual and anti-reality
uh and i while university of chicago
seems to be falling into line along with
the rest of the institutions
which i can't quite fully uh understand
i would say that there are certainly
many many people
out here who are looking for good
fiction that is not that is not woke
so there has to be an audience figuring
out how to get
uh the books that are excellent and not
woke into the hands of people who are
looking for such books
is trickier
if the police are defunded next question
then how will they afford the 20 to 30
thousand
dollars that roman d'angelo charges to
be a keynote speaker and thereby let
them know how racist they are
just saying thanks for the dark horse
wisdom
yep yeah
as a web dev and college student with
zero biology background
where should i go to get an introduction
to evolutionary biology which book
should i read first or podcast or else
wish you both the best keep up the great
work
um so what i would say is
for years we have recommended dawkins
selfish gene as the starting point
it's what we often started with in our
own programs yeah it was the first book
we assigned
had them had them read it before they
showed up for the first day class and if
you get a
the most recent edition it comes with
extensive
endnotes where dawkins himself has
tracked so the book was written in 76 or
it was published in 76
and he tracks where he was right where
he was wrong
what we now know that kind of thing so
it's very well done
i will say there is a missing there are
a couple of missing elements
and maybe most important is
the fact that in 76 there was almost
nothing to say about molecular
epigenetics and it is playing such an
important role in our understanding of
of mechanistic biology that its absence
from the book does
result in it being dated but in any case
it is
an excellent starting place that's what
you've asked for it's an excellent
starting place it deals with
the introductory game theory it deals
with the introductory
genetics it deals with um all sorts of
things
that are well worth understanding so i
would say start there yeah uh i guess
on sort of the other side of
evolutionary biology probably that's
exactly what you're looking for and it's
it's exactly where we started but if
you're looking for the
macroevolutionary stuff the sort of um
history of species
and species level evolution another
dawkins book
actually is uh even less dated and a
wonderful read and does give you some of
the other theoretical things without
going into game theory and micro
evolution population level stuff which
is an ancestor's tale
in which he takes um he basically takes
a tour back
um through his through humans back
through history to the origins of life
on earth
by looking at what each of our most
recent common ancestors
or some extent relative of them might
look like now and
and takes from that
stories that he can tell about genetics
about development et cetera
it's really quite good yeah ancestors
too it's brilliant
if you think about the tree of life and
all of the branchings that took place
uh on the way to being modern humans he
goes back to each of the nodes
yeah um and actually as long as we're on
this
topic um if adaptation
rather than evolution in the larger
sense is what you're after if adaptation
is what you're after then um climbing
mount improbable
is quite beautiful it's all doggons it's
all dark
well i mean look yeah if you're looking
you know if you're looking for what a
modern
view of evolutionary theory looks like
dawkins is a great starting place now
the question you should be asking is why
have we made so little progress
from what dawkins understood and that's
a question i put to dawkins and got
what i consider to be an absurd answer
which is that basically we got it all
right which can't possibly be true given
what we still don't understand
now the book that we will have published
next year
is not meant to be a primer on evolution
exactly
but it does provide a lot of the tools
that we are talking about as well
yep all right
uh hi bretton heather i really enjoy
listening to discussions i live in
portland and i have identified 31 laws
currently going unenforced and four
related to dereliction of duty
i'd like to start a suit and need a good
lawyer do you know any second part of
the question because
there's two here hardesty said seven
million dollars plus was spent on police
ot i'm not sure what um overtime police
overtime
they could have ended the riots weeks
ago anyone living in portland can submit
a fraud or waste claim against the city
and state on the secretary of state
website
that's interesting so do we know a good
lawyer
the problem is good lawyer is an
oxymoron skilled lawyer
now there we know a few we don't know
any in portland though no they're not in
portland unfortunately no we don't know
any lawyers in oregon
yeah and you don't want a good lawyer
because it holds them back you want a
shark
that's what you want um you're not
helpful i'm not helping at all
was i trying to be healthy i think i was
no but i was not succeeding at it no i
think you were trying not to be helpful
and you were succeeding
ah well i feel better about it yes yes
important portland timeline tower boy
important portland timeline addendum
the riots shifted focus specifically to
the courthouse around july 4th
after the feds began clearing
demonstrators blocks away from the
federal property
okay i didn't i did not remember that
is it possible that the hatred of the
cisgendered and nuclear family is
because transsexuals feel excluded from
natural reproduction family formation
for the record i think the move is being
disingenuous in their trans support
yeah i think um
i think just like with the
protest riot movement that we see that
looks like a majority of people are
getting behind right now
the trans the trans movement
uh appears to be something that we all
need to get behind because it's the
newest civil rights
thing um but in fact you know in fact
the question uses the word transsexual
most of the people who are the trans
rights activists the tras the trans
rights activists
are not the transsexuals of the 50s 60s
70s 80s
these are activists who are cosplaying
at being something that they are not and
that is not to suggest that there aren't
real trans people with real
uh gender dysphoria and uh you know a
disconnect somehow for some
developmental reason
between what their chromosomal and
anatomical and brain and behavioral
sex and gender say they are there's
there's a disjunction between those
manifestations of sex and it's
excruciating and
and we know some people who experience
this and it's awful
that's not most of what's going on
though and so um
i would say i actually object in the
same way that you often object when i
want to
try to put you know a good
try to explain something uh to the best
of my ability with a good spin like you
know what i i'm actually so out of
patience with these people
on this one that i'm not i'm not even
going to
provide them ammunition to come back
even though even though i don't i don't
buy their arguments at all and in fact i
think
the next question is is related here so
you may want to add something but the
next question
is um and it comes with a smiley face
emoticon uh if congress was 50 cis men
and 50 male to female trans women would
you agree that it had a good gender
split
[Laughter]
yes this is this is exactly the problem
yeah right there yeah no it's the
problem is
there is an uh an
honest compassionate argument for
protection of trans people however it
creates a loophole
for certain folks who want to use this
designation as a shield for
doing all kinds of harm and so somehow
you have to do
these two things you have to develop the
protection for people who need the
protection
without creating the loophole for people
who would exploit it that's right
oh thank you bretton heather you all
stay safe we will
thank you progressives paradox
if a disabled trans person of color
states i think a person's argument
should be judged on its own merit rather
than the level of perceived victimhood
of the person saying it
what happens uh it's a matter
anti-matter
yeah expressive paradox yeah right it's
yeah
it's troubling but i mean we have
exactly this phenomenon without quite so
many parameters
right we there you know there's no
shortage of
um courageous highly cogent
black voices pointing out how crazy
this movement is right there's there's
all sorts of
evidence that this is not simply some
conclusion that we've all arrived at
because
um because it's clear basically
everybody who's thinking carefully knows
that it isn't
what's being portrayed so yeah anyway
well stated been watching these for the
past few weeks and i've never been so
delightfully terrified
thank you for doing these yes we aim to
delightfully terrify
yeah what probability would you assign
the hypothesis that the woke movement
slash ponzi scheme
is in part the result of another country
conducting social media inception
on america's young progressive
population well there's a question about
cause and amplification i don't know
what i would say
about the chances that it is
fundamentally initiated as an experiment
from
outside the country but i would say the
chances that none of our enemies
are amplifying this online is pretty
small
because obviously the hazard that it
poses
to the through the mighty u.s is so
great
that if we can get us to self-sabota if
some they can get us to self-sabotage
they will do it
um so yes but you know is it enough to
have altered things substantially
who knows it's a question that should be
studied using something like logic and
science were it not for the fact that
those are apparently white supremacists
and tools of the patriarchy and tools of
the patriots yes well said
and cis people
[Music]
this i'm not sure what it's apropos i
don't remember if one of us said
something
uh to this effect there are no
accidental discharges there were only
negligent discharges
full stop yeah now that must be
referring to the
rally in louisville and the fact that
somebody apparently discharged a weapon
so anyway i think this is a
a a literally false metaphorically true
extension of all firearms are loaded
you know there are no accidental
discharges
because you loaded the weapon something
like that yeah
and now for something completely
different you spoke of how dreams could
be a way of your subconscious offering
you insights
can you speak further of the
evolutionary reasons for dreams and do
you suppose lucid dreaming could be a
further enhancement of this process
sweet question yeah all right
i will say the primary
value of dreams so first of all i should
say the more you dig into this the more
you discover that there are lots of
different kinds of dreams and that one
person's dreams don't look like another
and so there is a huge landscape to be
explored here
and one thing i have been saying forever
is that we should figure out what
hunter-gatherers
uh dream about before there are no more
hunter-gatherers because it would be
wonderful to know what the base state
was
but what we can say is that an
awful large percentage of dreams appear
to be
scenario building that is to say while
your brain is not occupied
by processing active incoming data it
takes
probabilistic uh it takes a
probabilistic look at things that you
fear things opportunities you might uh
avail yourself of
and it runs you through scenarios so
that when you get to these things it's
not your first time through
right it doesn't have to be fully
rendered it just has to be good enough
and you have to suspend your disbelief
enough
that when the scenario hits you can sort
of try it out
and i will say i've learned one thing
about scenarios from my own experiments
with lucid dreaming
which is if i'm lucid dreaming it's a
difficult state to get to but if i can
get there
and then i say well this is my brain
writing this story i should be able to
predict what's going to happen next
it never works it literally has never
once worked right that tells you
something it tells you you're saying
that the prediction has been wrong
every time every single time as if to
have predicted it is to invalidate that
storyline like
the whole point of scenario building
would be
to run you through things that you don't
see coming so right
and so my point would be whatever part
of your brain makes the movies
the conscious part of your brain is not
allowed in because the
thing wouldn't work it wouldn't be
valuable to you if it was so
yeah um your dreams are not a safe space
my dreams are very dangerous i have to
say
i'm not talking about your dunes in
particular but i mean i think that the
the hypothesis here is that
dreams are explicitly not a safe space
they are where your consciousness
goes to actually make you safer in your
waking life but that means that they're
going to put you in in apparent danger
in your sleep space yeah there's no
point in running you through scenarios
in which
things are all cool and nothing's going
to go wrong so my dreams are really
about stuff going wrong all the time
but that explains why you sleep the way
you do i guess it does it's
a little bit chaotic but um okay as to
your final question about
lucid dreams lucid dreams i believe
are an occasional phenomenon which may
be
adaptive that is to say the discovery
that you are in a dream which usually
wakes you up
so learning to stay asleep through that
is um not easy but nonetheless it
happens at some low rate
under normal circumstances for people
who have not trained themselves
but training yourself to stay asleep
even when you become lucid which
it's exhausting but it's fascinating
what you will discover you do and don't
have control over
that is a hack right you're not supposed
to have conscious access to your dreams
you can gain it you will lose stuff you
will gain stuff
so i would say to the extent that humans
hack their own cognition this is a
totally valid hack and i'm sure
that it has important uh
positive evolutionary outgrowths
but probably mostly it is not um
the reason that we don't have lucid
dreams is that in general that does not
bring you the highest value
let's just do a couple more here and
then we'll switch to the next
live stream questions interested to know
if the two of you have an opinion on
submitting data to 23andme
with an adopted father and maternal
grandmother it's very tempting
i'm not into conspiracy theories but i'm
also aware that they'd have my dna
forever
yeah we haven't done it for exactly this
reason
concerns about privacy and uh it
it looks like you have to sign away your
rights to your own dna
in order to to get results now you could
do it anonymously
which means that your data won't plug in
and be able to help other people
understand their own
genealogies if you slot into a
particular place etc
but it would protect you in terms of
linking
anything that is learned um to your
personal identity um that seems like
the only way that i know we haven't even
done that
it might protect you yeah exactly it
might protect you if somebody was
really interested they could figure out
who you were
using a composite of who you're related
to
and other available information right so
i would say none of this is safe
and you know there's one way in which
you know a large
part of 23andme may in fact be kind of
like a
facebook gamble where yeah the point is
actually
you're the product your information is
the valuable commodity
and that you get a free service for it
so this would be a nominal
charge to collect your dna and i think
your concerns are
are warranted they're they're warranted
and yet um
you know having an adopted father a
maternal grandmother of course you'd be
curious
my brother's adopted i think that um i
think that it's
even more intriguing if you have
if it's not just i wonder if the family
stories are true or
can i add more detail uh to the family
stories but i actually don't have family
stories and i'd really like some i'd
really like to have some sense
um and of course it can also aid in um
in disease prediction yep
so it's it's tricky and i think we just
we need
we need better regulation of this
particular industry before you or i are
gonna feel safe doing it
yeah i agree yeah
um i want the freedom to fight against
brett's ideas in an honest forum
thank you both for your dedication to
the republic and next question same
person
also thank you for bringing the concept
of game theory and tragedy of the
comments into common conversation
so does this person find my stuff
particularly objectionable is that
i don't know this is someone who's asked
questions before
um uh i think you know the idea is
i don't think particularly my guess is
but um it's hard to imagine that they're
here asking
questions in the super chat if they find
me particularly terrible but
honest forum honest form all right well
i'm all for honest forums
yeah for uh i think for uh yeah not
foreign
yeah uh last question here and then
we'll switch to the
next um this one is a two-part totally
different questions would you consider
having youtube lectures on game theory
and do you have any thoughts on the eu
as a european myself i'm worried that
this project is fundamentally flawed and
undemocratic
um yeah so
the first question what i've now
forgotten
uh youtube lectures on game theory well
there definitely is a need for
some sort of lectures on game theory um
i do think
you can be you can teach yourself game
theory well but i mean we we get this
question a lot and the fact is there
aren't good
there there is no good text to point
people to there are a couple of papers
here and there
um and it is far easier to do it in real
time
with people who already have facility
with the tools and can who can sort of
show you when you've when you've made an
error in your thinking yeah
um i feel like i'm surprised if there is
not and therefore i wonder if there in
fact
is not a good youtube series on game
theory
already i don't know of one i'd be
curious um
to hear about it if if people think that
there are david
sirock oh yeah was working on one
and i saw very good stuff from him
initially so i don't know
i should check in on that project and
see but you know you kind of need
animations
yeah um to make these things clear and
so anyway i'm very hopeful that he's
produced exactly the thing you're
looking for
okay let's rock s-a-r-a-c yeah
uh and then the eu oh the eu right
well i'm in favor of the eu but i'd like
to see it move offshore
no um
well it all depends on the structure you
put water in my water i did put water in
your water
um it's a little practical joke i was
playing on you
um yeah let's put it this way i'm not
i'm not an expert on the structure
there's obviously an advantage
to federation there's a hazard to
federation the brits are now
involved in both the hazard of
federation and the
hazard of trying to extract themselves
from it um
so uh
i don't know enough about it to say but
i would say uh my guess is
was not done very well because it was
naive about things like um
game theory but um
was some sort of federation necessary is
it a
proper hedge against another world war
started in europe maybe
so anyway mixed bag would be the answer
okay questions from this live stream
the latest glenn show with john
mcwhorter was stellar john mentioned
that we need a word for the identitarian
left
i've seen and like thinkquisitors other
ideas
um yeah we've called it the works golds
the woke army
um plague of wokists
um oh uh how about this one
um the civil wrongs movement
that's good yeah yeah it's it's the it's
the
movement level name rather than the
you know the civil wrongs activists yeah
i have a feeling they won't like it well
they're not like the inquisitors
or plague of locusts or wokes golds
either there's a lot to work with
there i mean they just did you know they
and
i was going to mock them a little bit
and i think it's not not
nice and maybe not accurate you know
they don't like social justice warriors
because it's been used as a as a epithet
um but it seems to me that that is what
they are trying to do that that is
actually
an an honest and just just thinking of
the words
um a description of what they claim to
be doing
now those of us who are speaking against
it say ah
that's not justice guys um you know
that's civil wrongs not civil rights
uh but that does actually seem to
describe
what they are but that's now seen as an
epithet and so calling them that
is seen as aggressive i i think it's
totally
illegitimate that it's seen as
aggressive because it's basically them
viewed
from their own lens they are warriors on
behalf of social justice it's like
calling antifa antifa even though you
don't think they're really fighting for
that i'm the anti-racist yeah
yeah so um at some level if you're
accepting somebody else's viewpoint to
name their movement you're doing them a
favor
and um to be chastised for it because
you're on the other side
is preposterous so yeah
are the dna strands
are the dna strands in a tit-for-tat
relationship
are the dna are
you talking about chromatids uh no like
the the five prime and the theoprime
strands oh right i think i think i think
um uh it continues would you agree that
all living things are engineered by tit
for tat
except for the number of variables e.g
a fur tree responds to less outside
stimuli than an
oak so this echo who's really really
smart
but also often tries to fit more into
her questions than we could quite make
sense of
yeah um i i don't it seems to me
if we're talking five prime if we're
talking uh
sense and inverse sense right we are
looking
at i an identity relationship
right basically the same information
yeah yeah that's just error correction
so you thought maybe chromatids but that
would be that's
that's that's not dna strands it's
strands yeah um
so i don't think so but it's you know
given that it's echo there's a good
chance that there's something in that
question that we're just not
getting from it um and then the so the
second part the question would you agree
that all living things are engineered
by tit for tat except for the number of
variables
well i guess i would say um
equilibrium is a very powerful concept
if you have not spent time
thinking about equilibrium it is worth
doing and that in some sense
i don't think it's tit for tat because
well it's a tit-for-tat sorry but
uh almost as assumes diatic right
it seems to be back and forth a b a b a
b
right and equilibrium accommodates more
variables and so it's sort of built into
the question but you can you
the dog does not like this explanation
you end up reaching equilibrium as many
more than two often variables
come to a sort of an uh an agreeable
tension with one another
um yeah i also don't like that
explanation but you're not going to
groan at me like the dog
no i wouldn't grant it you like the dog
does um for one thing i'd be second best
at it and yeah
she's really good yeah she is um no i
yeah i don't see it i don't think it's
tit for tat i think it's some
a higher order process that uh manifests
tit for tat under some circumstances but
tit for tat basically
is limited to the universe where there's
something to be
one um and
you know in the case of the strands of
dna
um the sense strand does not win at the
expense of the inverse strand so
i think it's just not not right whereas
sister chromatids
will be in in conflict with one another
you know parent and offspring are in
conflict but you know there's there's
plenty of conflict to be found there's
plenty of
evolutionary theory to be had right but
not not in terms of the strands of dna
yep um oh
final part of the same of echo's
question are explorer modes
tit for tat looking for new partners
um again i think it's
i think it's not quite the right
expansion
i don't think tit for tat is the thing
that we're trying to expand here i don't
think it quite
works if an explorer mode let's say the
simplest version of an explorer mode is
um
you know critters trying to find a
watershed they haven't found yet let's
say we're talking about salmon
um then it's not really looking you know
the watershed isn't a partner to the
salmon
the watershed is indifferent to the
salmon yeah um so
yeah not quite no and that's actually i
mean that's another that's something i
don't think i don't know that we've
mentioned
ever yet in our live streams but this
distinction between
having you know an organism coming up
against an abiotic versus a biotic
force you know they've some darwin
famously described hostile forces
and he included in the hostile forces
that an organism has to contend with
which selection is responding to
things including weather and geography
and climate and also predators and
competitors and would-be mates and
pathogens
and the things in them that first list
the abiotic things the weather and the
climate and the geography
do not respond to the organism who is
responding to it
it is it is this immovable force that
does what it does regardless of whether
or not
you know when a when a volcano erupts
the other volcanoes don't
don't give a damn there's there's no
response there whereas predators
competitors con specifics
heterospecifics pathogens
all of these things can respond and can
evolve in response
and therefore there's a tit-for-tat
that's possible you can't have a
tit-for-tat with a river
no you'll lose for one thing
it starts to betray the point i just
invalidated your entire explanation
one glib remark but uh well and and
actually you know with with a river you
can you can change you can
actively change the course of a river
and the river will then you know move
away from you but it's not
it's not it's not the same
as if it was an organism yeah it's just
the difference between
realms in which there's uh an objective
in realms in which there's no objective
right i had a vision yesterday
standing between writers and federal
officers what are the chances that a
group of strong courageous patriots of
various backgrounds could peacefully
protest the rioters
would there be violence no matter what
um yeah uh good thought
yeah question is who's who's ready um
it has to be a large enough group and a
reasonable enough group and a careful
enough group
uh to pull it off and a group that
doesn't
somehow it has to
not be reducible even if this is a
complete
lie by the rioters to that's
you know trump fascist that's nazis
that's oh it will be
i mean right so how like how how does
that part get avoided well you have to
you have to be impervious to it yes you
will be accused of
partnering but individuals being
impervious doesn't mean
uh that the new york times won't tell
the story it tells the new york times
will tell the story it tells
you have to be impervious to that too
and so you know
look we've lost the new york times i
don't know whose idea that was
but somebody's a good one no it was it
was bad the new york times it's not a
newspaper anymore and
um that's a big loss um it's not a new
loss
it's been coming for a long time and the
last vestiges of
reason are fleeing the building but
um literally yeah
yeah from my daughter days
one what causes white's tree frogs
littoria cerullia
to change color she's watched hers do so
for years too the wood frog
lithobates sylvicus what causes their
heart to restart
after cryopreservation yeah
heather um
let me go with the wood frog first uh
that's a new genus you're giving it
um i assume that this is um this is it's
just had a name change since i last
checked in with this frog
um if it is the frog i'm thinking of it
is in
um is present in sort of the middle uh
mid-continental uh north america us
up into uh southern canada and these
frogs
actually uh get frozen solid frozen
solid not just their hearts but during
hard winters they they estimate they
bare
they bury under and then they don't even
keep
anything going they just become ice
cubes like if you dig them up
and uh you drop them they shatter
and then we are not advising that you do
that they don't restart after they
shatter
frogs you heard it here first frogs do
not restart after they shatter
um unlike starfish
you could shatter a starfish uh you can
prune the legs off
ah it's a little different from
shattering it's less dramatic
yeah yeah okay well these are the tools
we have as biologists
yeah so what is the actual mechanism
of restarting i i don't know at like the
cellular level
um but there is a kind of anti-freeze
um i think in these guys um that
basically begins to circulate
as the frog begins to thaw and they can
only deal with so many
well so so slow a freeze thaw cycle and
so many of them within
x number of weeks and so you know
particularly
chaotic springs for instance can leave a
you know an iowa landscape bereft of
these frogs because they just they
they don't come out of it successfully
but if they thaw slowly
and better off if it's just once um they
uh they restart but i don't i don't have
there's a big black box there in the
explanation that i don't know more about
i'm gonna take a crack at it okay i'm
gonna predict that um
predict is one of these things where
it's a prediction because i don't know
it doesn't mean nobody knows
but i'm going to predict that there is
a battery-like
set of cells that
is positioned in the tissue
such that it does not take what little
energy it has accumulated
and fire it off too early that is to say
while the heart is still partly frozen
and therefore would damage itself or be
unable to start
there is some battery that on that
thaws at the right moment that the heart
is capable of restarting it's not too
early it's not too late
and that it sends a signal to the
pacemaker which basically
functions as a defibrillator hmm oh i
like that
yeah yeah i don't know if that's true
nope neither do i
yeah it's a prediction uh with regard to
the white's tree frogs
uh what causes them to change color i do
not
remember what the mechanism is on those
guys there are a number of mechanisms of
color change in
mostly reptiles but also a few frogs um
that involve basically chromatophores
these you know just
the things in the skin that can that can
flip that are
often usually uh effectively a toggle
and they're binary and they can go from
one to the other but obviously there are
some
um over in reptile space not just
chameleons that have a
of a continuum and that's a different
mechanism and i don't know what
i do cephalopod mollusks have i think a
wide range
yeah i think they i think that that's a
different evolution entirely whereas i
think what's going on in
a few frogs and many more squamates um
is a shared i think a shared evolution
whereas the cephalopods is going to be
you know a different different evolution
of color change i'm going to say
and then some fish too and so i don't
know if the fish like the actinops like
rayfin fish that do this
um is a separate evolution from the
other vertebrates
don't know yeah and even if they are
separate evolutions probably there's
some precursor that they
share yes this is the way it is with the
vision pigments and stuff
but uh i think it's melancholy that
causes these frogs to
change color melancholy yeah i think
that's probably right
frogs are a sad lot oh sometimes
um i did see probably on reddit recently
somebody
posted in uh maybe it's the
nature is [ __ ] lit subreddit um
a video of a cephalopod i think an
octopus
um it's a child's question man oh sorry
well it's just it's a subreddit i'm just
quoting i didn't name it
um in any case they posted a video of
a and i'm sure it was an octopus um
changing color in its dream state which
raises all kinds of
dream state did you say how do we how do
we know
well because it appears to be an
adornment also cephalopod's dream
that's the thing is it's like how many
different convergences
are because so you know how is it that
we
uh can so quickly say oh well color
change and cephalopods it's going to be
a different evolution from color change
in vertebrates and even more easily
immediately conclude well if
cephalopods if octopi and squid or some
of them dream
then it's going to be a separate
evolution of dreaming than what we have
because we see evidence of dreams in
many mammals
i don't know if there's any evidence in
birds
but i don't think that i've seen anyone
discuss the possibility
of dream state in any of the other
non-mammalian vertebrates which means
the most recent common ancestor of
humans mammals and cephalopods is
how many hundreds of millions of years
ago like
six seven i i don't know i'm making that
number up but
more than it's early i don't know yeah i
don't know
and those organisms weren't dreaming
because we have
no evidence of dreaming in almost any
organisms that we've looked at so
these guys are dreaming says who looks
like how do we know well
you know i guess you would say uh you
would have
brain activity uh incidentally
different evolution of brains yep
different evolution of brains but you
would be able to detect the electrical
impulses associated with processing that
is taking place while the animal's not
taking in new
data yeah and i would say you know
painting with a broad brush
that's dreams okay um it's at least
processing
whether or not there's i guess
dreams for us is always tied into visual
cortex stuff right
yep there's there's at least memory of
visual
stuff uh even i believe for blind people
right uh so uh we obviously can't
interview the occupy yet we cannot they
just don't cooperate yeah they really
they're not interested
no no so we can see that there's
processing going on but we don't know
what the subjective experience is like
for them
can we what would it take for you guys
to pick up and leave portland
you trying to get us to leave well let's
see i've had several phone calls in the
last week suggesting that would be a
good idea
interestingly several of those calls
came from california where people are
actually picking up and leaving so
um yeah we're in kind of a pickle
when we moved here from olympia
we told our children that we wouldn't
move again we wouldn't move them again
before they were done with school um
which seemed really important because of
the
the total chaos that they experienced
because of what happened at evergreen
yeah um so that is that is something
that keep
and and you know there's so much about
portland and the pacific northwest to
love
uh but uh certainly there are certain
there are things that could cause us to
leave
for example like perhaps um defunding
the police
and leaving us to fend for ourselves
yeah
i i just don't know what else to think i
mean at some level it's such a dumb
experiment to run
but uh how successful
are we likely to be defending ourselves
against
who knows what yeah we have a dog that
moans
what is the likelihood of a free and
fair election in november
i am concerned that the current unrest
could emerge on election day and
undermine the democratic process
widespread violence can suppress and
intimidate voters
um yeah unity 2020 might be the way to
go on that
i mean one of the i don't know what the
chances are what are the chances
that it's going to be a hundred percent
free and fair there's zero because no
election
in a large population is going to be a
hundred percent free and fair will
somebody file a
phony ballot somewhere but what are the
chances that the election is free enough
and fair enough that it actually
represents the will of the people
pretty high what are the chances that
the will of the people is coherent
pretty low unless of course you consider
unity 2020 then of course it could but
you know voting for either of these
major parties that's not really the will
of the people so much that's the will of
the people
given constraints that are absolutely
unimaginably foolish
how can we progress with effective
reform of use of forced police
no let me start again how can we
progress with effective reform
of use of force policies and procedures
when demands are being made by those
with zero expertise
and where officer safety is clearly
absent i'm
a l-e-o parenthesis ireland
i don't know what leo stands for uh it's
an astrological sign
i think not but i don't know i mean the
question is obviously a good one yeah
you cannot allow people who know nothing
about this process and may
in many cases not even be well
intentioned to dictate terms you just
can't it would be insane to do so and so
um you know when you've got three
west coast mayors now
playing with these ideas something has
gone very
seriously awry no i think uh
what's a london breed is it in san
francisco is as well four
yeah yeah yeah um
have you seen german contact tracing
event plan
4 000 at the concert event in august
please comment
i haven't seen this from just that
really brief blurb it sounds
uh intriguing yeah if they're i mean if
they're going to have a big concert then
the idea that they're going to
contact trace afterwards uh potentially
provides a
huge epidemiological database uh that
will be you know
great if no one's sick and how super
useful if a few people do get sick and
then we see how it spreads
uh it does remind me
law enforcement officer all right so not
an astrological sign not a lion
it does remind me that i promised we
would talk about covet on today's
live stream and events in portland and
their implications
overwhelmed that plan so we will bump
that
to the next live stream all right
exactly an hour okay we will do four
more
okay mainstream anthropology explains
that humans have become agriculturalists
only 10 000 years ago
could this have been a re-emergence of
culture following a global cataclysm
might there be an evolutionary bio-angle
to this idea
so the evidence the archaeological
evidence suggests that
agriculture evolved convergently
separately
many places uh ranging from ten to
twelve thousand years ago and then a few
places like the new world
um probably more recently than that um
but certainly in isolation in the new
world uh and
um there's there's no archaeological
evidence to suggest
agriculture from you know 20 or 30 or
more than that thousand years ago uh so
i don't
uh i and you know we have both gone
looking for
the the strange the fringe the what-if
ideas
um around you know a lot of human
prehistory including the origins of
agriculture so
i don't think um i also i've just never
even seen any glimmerings of like i
found this and it's been buried because
mainstream
anthropology doesn't want to hear this
that said um
i will be anything but shocked if there
are precursors that are more
agricultural than we understand
in other words yes um people having
noticed that seeds produce plants
who may drop those seeds in places that
they would find convenient to go
forage later likely it exists just as
there are
precursors of uh evolutionary thinking
that have largely been lost to history
some things are um so important
canonical clear for those who have been
thinking about them that my guess is
there will be precursors yeah and the
order of operations isn't
inherently what it would seem so for
instance bread seems to predate
agriculture in boy i think it's two
places i think maybe south china
agriculture seems to have emerged twice
probably independently within within
modern china and i think it's in
southern china and maybe
in sort of mesopotamia uh there's
evidence of bread
before agriculture so um that's not
exactly to this point but the idea that
things go in this you know obviously
linear progression
uh and you know ceramics too uh were
widespread in some places long before
agriculture whereas
in some places probably agriculture you
know basically created the need
for vessels in which to hold grains
so these things these things are very
different in the many
many places where they have evolved
hi this question begins i believe that j
cole
describes the afro-american slice of
existence eloquently he would probably
work with you for unity 2020. are you
familiar with him
nope nope i don't mark that i don't know
j cole either
zach would you mark that that's line 84
it looks like
um second to last question viral
exposure as metaphorical transfusion of
virions
question mark it explains the benefit of
recipient
type o and dependence upon a and b
within population
for resistance to novel virus for
instance
china versus south american blood type
distributions against
covet 19.
i don't get it on one reading yeah viral
exposure as metaphorical
don't know if tran i think transfusion
isn't maybe the right word since
the transmission of varions um and
i don't know what is the first viral
exposure
metaphorical as metaphorical
transmission of virions
are they talking about
non-successful infections
in which contact is creating an as-if
vaccine is that the
yeah i i think that's right um
and then the you know explains the
benefit of recipient type o
um but then you know it it falls apart a
little bit
the the very question isn't quite um
accurate in terms of what i haven't
looked into this in the last month and a
half or so or two months
um but early on it looked like oh was
resistant
um to cover 19 but a was particularly
susceptible at b
b and a b were not particularly
susceptible so it wouldn't just be a
blanket like do you have
um you know do you have things stuck to
your your
to your blood or not right it's it's not
o versus a b and a b
a b and a b um so it's not it's not at
least clean but there
there might be something here this is a
question we need to engage with
the person to get more out of it final
question
my home-schooled son is off to college
soon
t-a-m-u i don't remember i can't
wait texas a m oh texas a m yep
texas a m i've tried to inoculate him
against the mind virus
i'm more worried about him catching the
mind virus than coronavirus
which do you think is worse um
oh wow well hopefully
you have laid the groundwork to make
resistance to
the woke virus highly likely
i would say the thing about coronavirus
is we just don't know how bad it is yet
because we don't know whether or not you
gain immunity
that's long lasting we don't know
whether it hides in some tissue and
recurs
if it's evolving towards more virulence
or less right
towards more transmissibility outside we
do know that it
um does an awful lot of organ damage
in some people so i would say
let's put it this way if your son comes
home
having been infected by the woke virus
he could
awaken from that zombie-like state and
regain his sense of reality the covet
thing
you're just rolling the dice with
respect to what kind of damage it's
gonna do and how long-lasting it is so
um i honestly don't i i appreciate the
question
very much um and i don't even know how
to put the two things next to each other
i don't know how to compare the risks
here
yeah um even though you know the mind
virus the woke mind virus very much
is acting like a virus and so it seems
like we should be able to answer this
question
um but they pose
we believe as if you're watching this
you know that the woke virus poses
actually an existential threat to
civilization
um yes but your son's participation and
it doesn't change how threatening it is
to civilization
right and your sense your son's um
you know brief dipping into it and
emerging perhaps inoculated more
strongly than he would have been
um might render him more powerful in the
world
whereas a brief dip into coronavirus um
probably does not make him stronger so
it's a tough question and i'm sort of
sorry to leave
without you know without any kind of
resolution on that
um however we have reached the end here
and uh once again we'll say we're doing
end of the live stream
don't panic we have not reached the end
of anything else that we're aware of
nothing we've reached the end of the
week check the internet
after we're offline here but hopefully
nothing i won't
i'm i'm done you're out i'm i am out i
am i'm gonna go outside and spend some
time in nature
um but tomorrow we will both be back
online um
at 11am for a private q a for people who
have joined my patreon at five dollars
or up we have
way too many questions already um but we
will
we're trying to juggle that and figure
out how to answer them uh at either of
our patreons at five dollars
and up uh you can get access to the
discord
here's a clips channel where some of the
little bits from these get posted now
what else
i think we'll be back the plan is to be
back on tuesday we'll probably start
dropping these to one a week
at some point soon but for now we'll be
back on tuesday
okay like subscribe comment
circulate all those things those are all
helpful to us we appreciate your support
and until next time be well
[Music]
you